bonsoir renaud muselier merci merci
d'être avec nous avant donc de réagir
comme on le disait sur les annonces des
manuels macron l'assemblée qui donne son
premier feu vert au texte controversé de
la loi dite de sécurité globale la
france soumise dit qu'on franchit la
ligne rouge avec ce projet de loi ce que
vous partagez cet avis chez les
républicains
je fais républicain je sais pas mais
pour ma part pas du tout moi j'aime bien
entendu votre reportage je les regardais
beaucoup l'attention aussi bien entendu
il faut toujours condamné toute forme de
violence quelle qu'elle soit notamment
la policière je pense que quand on est
un pays de droit et que les migrants se
doivent de respecter le droit et la loi
française et parallèlement à ça ceux qui
les soutiennent ce que je peux très bien
comprendre feu doivent aussi respecter
la loi française et fait en sorte qu
avant la manifestation organisée la mise
en place de tenter dé mode de défense
pour faire en sorte que la loi française
ne soit pas respecté et organiser une
résistance pour des migrants qui sont en
situation régulière paraît incohérente
ce qui concerne la loi vu voter au
parlement
vous savez dans une situation très
compliquée comme la nôtre on peut avoir
des couples de policiers qui ont été
dénoncées sur le net avec des adresses
donné les nouveaux téléphones données et
après des violences à leur endroit
voir leur assassinat fait en sorte que
je peux faire quand même déjà défendre
la police dans ces situations là qui
font un métier particulièrement
difficile qui doit être parfaitement
cadré dans le cas de l word général et
vous restez avec nous s'il vous plaît
renaud muselier puisque le président de
la république a donc pris la parole il y
à une heure parmi les annonces la
possibilité de sortir jusqu'à 20 km et
durant trois heures à partir du 28
novembre
la réouverture des commerces
essentiel avec des protocoles sanitaires
renforcés les stations de ski qui
resteront elles fermées les aides aux
entreprises fermées augmenter jusqu'à
20% du chiffre d'affaires de premières
vaccinations anti copie de son sont
également envisagés fin décembre ou
début janvier ces dernières ne seront
pas obligatoires le président qui a
appelé à tout faire pour éviter une
troisième vague et un troisième
confinement je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de son allocution
la deuxième étape ce sera le 15 décembre
le 15 décembre
si nous sommes bien arrivés autour des
5000 contamination par jour et environ
2500 à 3000 personnes en réanimation
nous pourrons alors franchir un nouveau
cap
alors le confinement pourra être levée
nous pourrons donc à nouveau nous
déplacer sans autorisation y compris
entre régions et passer noël en famille
il faudra au maximum limité les
déplacements inutiles souffler et se
retrouver oui mais j'en appelle à votre
sens des responsabilités il ne s'agira
pas à coup sûr de vacances de noël comme
les autres les activités extrascolaires
en salle pour l'accueil des enfants
durant les fêtes seront à nouveau
autorisée avec des règles strictes les
salles de cinémas les théâtres les
musées pourront reprendre leurs
activités
toujours dans le cadre des protocoles
sanitaires qui ont été négociées et un
système de roda tâche permettra
d'organiser les représentations en cinq
journées et donc nous sommes toujours
avec renaud muselier président à la
région sud provence alpes côte d'azur
renaud muselier vous avez donc j'imagine
suivi cette locution d' emmanuel macron
il voulait me donner un cap
le président de la république mission
accomplie ce soir selon vous en tout cas
il a nommé un cap et a fixé des
objectifs avec un calendrier est ce que
la mission est accomplie dans la mesure
où ils allument au bout d'un tunnel une
petite lumière c'est déjà un énorme
énorme évolution
ceci est suffisant pour les commerces
une très bonne nouvelle pour la culture
c'est très bien pour sauver noël il ya
encore du travail parce que finalement
on a très grosse difficultés sur les
commerces de deux mois pour les
commerces c'est pas possible il faut
revoir ça avoir une clause roux a lieu
au 15 décembre si effectivement la crise
sanitaire s'améliore faut pas laisser
fermer deux mois quand même c'est pas
possible
parallèlement à ça sur les stations de
ski peut quand même les réouvrir puisque
c'est de l'extérieur sans pour autant
ouvrir les restaurants je pense que
c'est l'ensemble de l'économie des
montagnes qui est un très grand père il
essaie des saisonniers et c'est
dramatique donc août et il ya pour la
première fois une lumière au bout du
tunnel
il faut savoir quelle est la longueur
des tunnels il faut donc accélérer de
marseille du côté de chez vous on a
entendu les restaurateurs ont exprimé
leur colère ya encore quelques semaines
ils vont devoir patienter jusqu'au 20
janvier puisqu'on va subir un couvre feu
de 21 heures à 7 heures du matin jusqu'à
au moins cette date et encore il faudra
que les la situation de permettre le 20
janvier une bonne décision selon vous de
maintenir ses restaurants fermer les
bars les discothèques également et les
salles de sport il ya plusieurs choses
qui sont différentes dans ce genre
d'activité en ce qui concerne les
restaurants il est clair que le soir
c'est un danger potentiel potentiel je
dis bien mais l'ouverture entre midi et
2 est tout à fait envisageable avec les
conditions sanitaires
en ce qui concerne les discothèques
c'est sûr que le danger réel et donc là
c'est encore plus compliqué quant aux
salles de sport c'est un je suis
soucieux encore aussi très partagés ce
qui est très important
immédiatement c'est que l'on ait la
possibilité à voir à cause d'une clause
de revoyure le 15 et ça moi je vous
donne un exemple très simple dans la
région pour un simple côte d'azur d'un
pensionnat c'est nous les chiffres de
ses fondements c'est encore stable avec
une diminution certaines en réanimation
et d'un milieu hospitalier
mais il n'y a plus aucune consultation
hua chu il ya plus appel au samu et les
chiffres de la de la coupe s'effondre
donc si dans quinze jours c'est à dire
dans le 15 décembre trois semaines ça
continue sur cette musique là où cette
distance aucune raison
puisse pas ouvrir soit entre midi et
deux soit aussi entre 17h et 21h au 19
heures et des clauses particulières
qu'on peut mettre en place ne peut pas
laisser la totalité de ces commerces
fermés encore deux mois vous êtes
beaucoup exprimés renaud muselier sur la
question des vaccins on va en parler
avec vous dans quelques instants mais je
voudrais vous faire réagir justement sur
ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état sur ce
sujet écouter le troisième outil enfin
qui nous permettra de faire face au
virus durant les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois et pour nous tous une
formidable lueur d'espoir c'est le
vaccin notre stratégie repose sur
plusieurs vaccins certains seront
disponibles dès la fin décembre début
janvier et une seconde génération
arrivera au printemps
notre plan en la matière est clair
d'abord sécuriser le nombre de doses
nous l'avons fait avec l'union
européenne et la commission en achetant
auprès des producteurs en nous mettant
en capacité d'en produire en maximum en
europe et le nombre de doses étant
répartis en fonction de la population de
chaque état membre
les premiers vaccins sous réserve des
résultats des essais cliniques pourront
être administré dès la validation des
autorités sanitaires compétentes et
renaud muselier vous aviez adressé une
lettre mardi à olivier ferrand vous
précié le ministre de la santé
d'anticiper les commandes de vaccins
craignant une je cite une pénurie rapide
d'europe on aura pardon en france
l'europe n'a pas anticipé assez selon
vous alors qui ralentit les procédures
est ce que vous voilà un petit peu
rassurés à emmanuel macron ce soir en
partie effectivement mais ma lettre à
lui des effets apparemment puisque de
toute façon quand j'écris là les
coeliaques dix jours nous étions en
attente de validation notamment sur le
modern art vous savez ce médicament sup
à remercier d'ailleurs quitte aux états
unis qui fait en sorte qu' il avait
signé avec le canada pays notamment les
pays du golfe et que les négociations
qui avaient commencé au mois d'août
n'étaient toujours pas définitif chez
nous donc en tout cas je sais pas si
c'est mon intervention
mais en tout cas ça a été des bleus
des débuts au niveau européen j'étais
intervenu aussi au niveau européen de
façon à ce qu'on puisse accélérer l
année dernier donc le président en
réseau ces vaccins sont aujourd'hui
engagés commandé par l'europe et
ventilés sur différents pays européens
tant mieux maintenant il ya une modalité
d'application de cette vaccination
comme lui je suis contre l'obligation de
vaccination mais parce que une
progression très simple un français sur
deux qui se vacciner ça fait grosso modo
35 millions de français vaccinés et donc
faut avoir une campagne de vaccination
exemplaire et je les fais j'ai fait
naître aujourd'hui à monsieur virant les
prisons de la république co signer avec
monsieur baroin et monsieur bussereau
les présidents des mairies de france et
des départements de france afin qu'on
fasse un copier-coller adapté ou votre
français avec sur le mode de la fac six
nations par les länder allemands qui ont
trois semaines d'avancé sur nous ou il
faut acheter dvd des frigos il faut
mettre en place des chaînes de
vaccination dans le câble c'est le
schème de vaccination nous avons la
capacité nous le territoire d'ailleurs
le président de la république en a parlé
nous avons une capacité d'action
immédiate
ceci en accord avec nos ars agences
régionales de santé afin que l'état
français commandes et que nous puissions
en accord avec la rs fait en sorte que
de façon sécurisée nous puissions avoir
ces campagnes de vaccination pourquoi
cette démarche parce que si dans la
première vague et nous avons été très
délicat si je puis dire en tout cas nous
étions dans la logique 2-0 polémique
avec le gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous ne voulons pas que le
misère la santé qui a raté le virage des
masques qui a raté le virage des tests
karaté beaucoup de virages en parlant
d'ailleurs souvent au nom du comité
scientifique du conseil scientifique
il faut remarquer d'ailleurs qu'il a
disparu du paysage c'est lui a tant
mieux d'ailleurs pas ce qui nous a fait
faire beaucoup de bêtises ou en tout cas
il a fait faire à nos gouvernants
beaucoup de bêtises
aujourd'hui faire en sorte qu' on puisse
ne pas rater la vague de vaccination qui
est nécessaire les territoires sont à
disposition nous sommes prêts et nous
sommes organisés en tout cas un comité
scientifique cherves
renaud muselier va suivre la compagne de
vaccination c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
chef de l'état mais ça doit pas être le
même ils auraient ils auraient mieux
fait d'ailleurs de lui donner une autre
dénomination parce que le prix celui là
il nous a vacciné de les écouter à
jamais merci en tout cas vous renaud
muselier d'avoir été avec nous pour
réagir bon kcna
on saute d'emmanuel macro